INCLUDING AN OVERTIME WINNER
OR NASHVILLE
WITH THE PUCK NOW SENT INTO THER
THE BLUE LINE AND IT IS A GLOVES
PLAYED VERY WELL AGAINST THE
TOMASINO
DOWN LOW.
GRANLUND, BEHIND THET IS ALWAYS
HARDER WHEN YOU LOSE CENTRE AND,
>> John S.: YES IN THIS DAY AND
AGE.
>> John G.: YES.
>> John S.: A SHOT THE WITH A
GOOD CHANCE, TURNED ASIDE IS OLN
WHO SENDS THAT PUCK AROUND FOR
PEARSON AND
SPORTS, YOUR LOCALG IT ACROSS F,
ALREADY.
>> John S.: THEY LOST BY ONE TO
OH, BOY, A AND IT IS BOESER, TG
PREDATORS,K TOT PUCK SENT
QUINN HUGHES, DRAGGING TO THE
REMAINS TIEIE
OUT FOR OVER A MINUTE AND THEY
ICE THAT PUCK BUT COU WHISTLE SE
CANUCKS WILL GO TO THE POWER
PLAY.
SEVEN-MINUTE MARK.
>> John G.: AND TOMASINO COMING
OUT OF T THERE.
AND DEMKO THAT TIME WITH
HÖGLANDER, DEKES, TUCKS IT IN!SS
TALKING TO DANE SIDE AND
EKHOLM, KUNINN HUGHES AND
HE COULD NOT GUT.
POOLMAN, MYERS, POOLMAN GOING
THIS IS EKHOLM NOW,
WIDE OPEN AND IN FRONT.
AND HERE, TO AND FOR
THROUGH THE LO PLAY IT
AND IT IS OFF OF EKMAN-LARSSON
AND RIGHT TOL AND THREE
CANUCKS THROUGH CENTRE AND
CHAISSON, CUTTING TO THE MIDDLE,